Jake: 明天火锅要干多久
Jake: How long will the hotpot take tomorrow?
Tasha: 我觉得如果是洗菜切盘的话
Tasha: I think if we wash and cut the vegetables,
Tasha: 可能会比较湿
Tasha: it might be a bit wet.
Tasha: 然后再不是现成的那个菜
Tasha: And then if it's not ready-made,
Tasha: 那也要洗了之后切了
Tasha: we'll need to wash and cut them too.
Lucia:  这片菜怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why are these vegetable slices so big?
Lucia: 算了我这舀进来吧
Lucia: Never mind, I'll just scoop them in.
Alice: 嗯但我感觉还是需要一个人准备一下
Alice: Hmm, but I think someone still needs to prepare a bit.
Katrina:  一个小时肯定要
Katrina: An hour is definitely needed.
Katrina:  嗯嗯然后呢就准备好
Katrina: Yeah, and then get everything ready.
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm haha.
Tasha: 开始可以放个电影把桌子挪远一点
Tasha: We can start by playing a movie and moving the table a bit further.
Katrina:  哇真的耶
Katrina: Wow, really.
Katrina:  对这个桌子挪那然后放东西也行
Katrina: Yeah, move the table and then we can place things properly.
Tasha: 看我今天的会议哈哈哈
Tasha: Check out my meeting today, haha.
小薇 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:  看新闻联播
Lucia: Watching the news broadcast.
Lucia: 好哈哈哈
Lucia: Okay, haha.
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 如果放电影或者综艺什么的
Lucia: If we play a movie or variety show,
Lucia: 可能还牵涉到什么版权之类的问题
Lucia: there might be some copyright issues.
Lucia: 会吗
Lucia: Right?
Lucia: 呃有吧
Lucia: Uh, maybe.
Lucia: 但是我觉得这个可能不是特别影响
Lucia: But I think it might not be a big deal.
Lucia: 哈哈i guess
Lucia: Haha, I guess.
Lucia: 会看春晚
Lucia: Watching the Spring Festival Gala.
Lucia: 假装我们是在春节期间采这个数据集
Lucia: Pretend we're collecting this data during the Spring Festival.
Lucia: 哦不行我们还有室外呢
Lucia: Oh no, we still have outdoor stuff.
Lucia: 那我们就说是在新加坡吧
Lucia: Then let's say we're in Singapore.
Lucia: 反正你们那四季如夏
Lucia: After all, it's summer all year round there.
Lucia: 啊还有大家在线
Lucia: Oh, and everyone is online.
Lucia: 在线弹幕聊天这么一个环节吗
Lucia: There's also an online chat section, right?
Lucia: 嗯哦就是咱们聊天的时候
Lucia: Hmm, oh, just while we're chatting.
Lucia: 那就再换一个吧
Lucia: Then let's switch to another one.
Jake: 东西就是我们比较耗时间的
Jake: The thing that takes most of our time is...
Jake: 准备是什么就是做这些手工吗
Jake: What preparations are we talking about? Like doing these handcrafts?
Katrina:  我的东西都差不多买好买好
Katrina: I've almost bought everything we need.
Jake:OK
Katrina: Okay, yeah, pressed it well.
Katrina:  东西已经买好了
Katrina: Everything's already bought.
Katrina:  然后今天你看买这个行吗
Katrina: So today, check if this is alright.
Katrina:  我们说材料还没有买
Katrina: We haven't bought the materials yet.
Katrina:  那就是我要等几天开始
Katrina: So that means I'll have to wait a few days to start.
Tasha: 你的话你看这是不是一种造型
Katrina: Do you think this looks like a design?
Tasha: 然后第二种造型
Tasha: And then the second design.
Tasha: 然后第三种然后第四种造型
Tasha: Then the third and the fourth designs.
Katrina:  气球是不是有点low感觉
Katrina: Don't you think balloons are a bit low-end?
Lucia: 可以买那种金属色气球
Lucia: We could buy those metallic balloons.
Katrina: 所有的活动都有气球
Katrina: Every event has balloons.
Katrina:  我看看我搜一下
Katrina: Let me check, I'll search it.
Katrina:  现在人家过几分钟
Katrina: Now, give me a few minutes.
Jake: 我觉得国内一
Jake: I think in our country,
Jake: 定会有那些很厉害的气球
Jake: there will definitely be some amazing balloons.
Jake: 就是啊呜咽那种各个形状
Jake: Like, you know, various shapes and stuff.
Jake: 吃火锅的话
Jake: If we have hotpot,
Jake: 在这吃中午还是晚上
Jake: should we have it for lunch or dinner?
Katrina:  应该得修硕回来是不是
Katrina: We probably need to rest first, right?
Katrina:  不然感觉他会生气
Katrina: Otherwise, he'd get upset.
Katrina:  晚上吃可以
Katrina: Dinner works.
Katrina:  晚上吃白天锻炼
Katrina: Dinner and then work out during the day.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You...
Katrina:  你的计划之前有要做的哪几件事
Katrina: What were the things you planned to do earlier?
Katrina:  没有剧本吗
Katrina: No script?
Katrina:  我没有剧本
Katrina: I don't have a script.
Lucia: 剧本你不是有剧本的吗
Lucia: Didn't you have a script?
Katrina:  我在这看
Katrina: I'm looking here.
Katrina:  你不是列了个表吗
Katrina: Didn't you make a list?
Jake: 是有剧本
Jake: There is a script.
Jake: 但是那个剧本是收底剧本
Jake: But that script is just a backup script.
Jake: 就是哈哈
Jake: It's like, haha.
Katrina:  明天下午如果修硕不到齐
Jake: If we don't get enough sales by tomorrow afternoon...
Lucia: 我们4个打麻将
Lucia: The four of us can play Mahjong.
Tasha: 他说不会
Tasha: He said he doesn't know how.
Lucia: 哦对哦他说不会哎
Lucia: Oh right, he said he doesn't know how.
Lucia: 其实我也不会
Lucia: Actually, I don't know how either.
Lucia: 但是你们可以教我
Lucia: But you guys can teach me.
Katrina:  就是明天如果修硕不在他要传出去
Katrina: So if the students aren't here tomorrow, he needs to leave.
Katrina:  我们4个打麻将
Katrina: The four of us can play Mahjong.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 对对给老板放一天假
Lucia: Yeah, let's give the boss a day off.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sounds good.
Lucia: 我们打麻将
Lucia: Let's play mahjong.
Lucia: 哈哈哈给他录一点
Lucia: Haha, record a bit of it.
Lucia: 对录一录一点
Lucia: Yeah, record a bit.
Lucia: 对录一点
Lucia: Just a bit.
Lucia: 这个传统
Lucia: It's a tradition.
Lucia: 传统技能
Lucia: Traditional skill.
Tasha:  真的吗一边打麻将一边转
Lucia: Really? Playing mahjong and filming at the same time?
Lucia:  动麻将真的很火
Lucia: Mahjong is really popular.
Lucia: 那个阿加莎克里斯蒂的那个罗杰一案
Lucia: In Agatha Christie's "Roger's Case,"
Lucia: 里面就是
Lucia: there's a part
Lucia: 有一段就是他们在打麻将
Lucia: where they're playing mahjong.
Lucia: 就是在英国的小镇上
Lucia: In a small town in England.
Lucia: 所以就当时老外已经知道
Lucia: So back then, foreigners already knew
Lucia: 中国有这么一项很传统的娱乐活动了
Lucia: that China had this traditional game.
Lucia: 我们知道他们亲眼见识一下
Lucia: They saw it with their own eyes.
Lucia: 就是Kristi写的
Lucia: That's what Kristi wrote.
Lucia: 这个麻将到底是什么样的
Lucia: What mahjong is like.
Tasha: 哈哈这附近有什么公园没
Lucia: Haha, is there a park nearby?
Katrina:  你当时不是说还要采集户外的那个吗
Katrina: Didn't you say we need to film outdoors?
Jake: 对户外
Jake: Yeah, outdoors.
Jake: 如果你没有最好可以
Jake: If you don't have a place, you can just take a walk.
Katrina:  什么排短去
Katrina: What about shooting a short drama?
Lucia: 拍短剧但是现在就是
Lucia: A short drama, but we don't have a script yet.
Lucia: 我们还没有一个现成的剧本
Lucia: If we start writing one,
Lucia: 如果开始写的话
Lucia: it'll take a few days.
Lucia: 那可能就已经好几天过去了
Lucia: We won't have time to shoot it.
Lucia: 就来不及拍了
Lucia: How about we film a dance?
Lucia: 拍个舞蹈
Lucia: We could do that.
Lucia: 可以那明天
Lucia: Maybe tomorrow.
Lucia: 明天明天咱们就练舞吧
Lucia: Let's practice dancing tomorrow.
Lucia: 要不请把我放在最边边
Lucia: Put me on the edge, though.
Alice: 我是个练舞
Alice: I'm practicing dancing.
Jake: 练舞不会
Jake: Dancing is hard.
Tasha: 跳舞我是个简单点的
Tasha: Dancing, I can handle simpler moves.
Katrina:  我想想容易顺拐的人
Katrina: I'm thinking about people who easily mess up.
Jake: 哈哈哈明天这些摄像头给你们当
Alice: Haha, the cameras will catch everything tomorrow.
Katrina:  我搜
Jake: Let me search.
Katrina:  还是颜颜消短剧吧哈哈哈
Katrina: Let's still shoot a short drama. Haha.
Tasha: 照着抖音演
Tasha: Let's imitate TikTok.
Tasha: 我先后毒消吗
Tasha: Should I go first?
Tasha: 啊不哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah no, hahaha
Lucia: 抖音也可以不过不过我不怎么看抖音
Lucia: TikTok is fine too, but I don't really watch TikTok.
Lucia: 大家有什么觉得比较好的
Lucia: Do you guys have any recommendations for good ones?
Lucia: 哔哩哔哩上面的也行
Lucia: Bilibili ones are fine too.
Lucia: 你自己哔哔上
Lucia: You can upload on Bilibili.
Lucia: 会牵涉版权吗
Lucia: Will it involve copyright issues?
Lucia: 会买是吗
Lucia: Will you need to buy it?
Katrina:  那就是我可以看起来喽
Katrina: So I can just watch it then.
Jake: 对哇
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  真的不用花自己的钱购物真的很爽
Katrina: It's really nice to shop without spending your own money.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 什么自己自己的房间也要装饰吗
Tasha: What, we have to decorate our own rooms too?
Tasha: 嗯啊那别人要参观房间吗
Tasha: Hmm, are people going to tour our rooms?
Katrina:  对房间吗
Katrina: Tour the rooms?
Jake: 你们
Katrina: You guys...
Jake: 是的你们要讨
Katrina: Yeah, you guys have to discuss it.
Jake: 就是可能每人整一主题什么的啊
Jake: Maybe everyone can choose a theme or something.
Tasha: 每个人有自己的风格
Tasha: Everyone has their own style.
Tasha: 好那我就
Tasha: Alright, then I'll...
Lucia: 我们还要装饰自己的房间
Lucia: We still have to decorate our own rooms.
Katrina:  那明天其实还要买东西啊
Lucia: So we actually need to buy stuff tomorrow.
Katrina:  买东西也挺费时间的
Katrina: Shopping takes a lot of time too.
Katrina:  挑东西买东西打麻将也挑
Katrina: Picking things, buying things, even playing mahjong takes time.
Alice: 那装饰自己的房间就是自己挑
Tasha: So decorating our own rooms means we get to choose ourselves?
Alice: 是的嗯
Alice: Yes, that's right.
Jake: 510算吧够吗
Jake: Is 510 enough?
Tasha: 耶一个人吗
Tasha: For one person?
Tasha: 一个人嗯好
Tasha: One person, alright then.
Alice: 我觉得我会找一个
Alice: I think I'll just find something.
Alice: 100多我都已经想好了
Alice: I've already planned to spend around 100.
Tasha: 剩下的钱能给我吗我就花100装饰
Tasha: Can I have the rest of the money if I only spend 100 on decorations?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina:  真好我们家要搬家
Katrina: It's great, our family is moving.
Katrina:  这个用完了
Katrina: Once this is done...
Katrina:  直接同步移到我的那个新房下楼哎
Katrina: I'll just move everything directly to my new place downstairs.
Lucia: 有道理哦
Lucia: Makes sense.
Tasha: 下楼了我还买一个风铃
Tasha: When I go downstairs, I'll buy a wind chime too.
Lucia: 天呐
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: 你知道我这个就是很讨厌收拾房间的
Lucia: You know, I really hate cleaning my room.
Lucia: 屁人
Lucia: Damn.
Lucia: 有多害怕别人来参观自己的房间吗
Lucia: Are you really afraid of others visiting your room?
Katrina:  你不要等我们装饰完
Jake: Don't wait until we finish decorating.
Jake: 先扫再扫
Jake: Sweep first, then sweep again.
Tasha: 呃先能把盆擦一下吗
Jake: Uh, can you wipe the basin first?
Jake: 能当然能
Tasha: Of course, I can.
Tasha: 把盆擦一下啊
Jake: Wipe the basin, okay?
Tasha: 对这两个也要擦哇
Tasha: Yes, these two also need wiping.
Tasha: 用这个
Tasha: What's this egg kept for?
: 这个这两个
Tasha: This one, and these two?
Lucia: 那个蛋是之前打失败了的蛋
Lucia: Those eggs were failed attempts from before.
Lucia: 先不用擦啊
Lucia: Don't wipe those for now.
Tasha: 那个不用擦先擦这种这个OK
Lucia: Leave those, wipe this one first, okay?
Alice: 给剩下白菜明
Alice: Save the leftover cabbage.
Alice: 天涮火锅好了
Alice: We can use it for hotpot tomorrow.
Lucia: 那盒蛋怎么办啊
Lucia: What about that box of eggs?
Lucia: 头大啊用
Lucia: Ugh, wrap it with cling film and put it in the fridge.
Lucia: 啊有道理
Lucia: Ah, makes sense.
Lucia: 明天给他炒了吧
Lucia: Let's cook it tomorrow.
Lucia: 火锅里能涮蛋吗
Lucia: Can you dip eggs in hotpot?
Lucia: 已经打开了的
Lucia: The ones that are already opened.
Lucia: 应该不可以吧
Lucia: Probably not, right?
Tasha:  就是那种店里涮牛肉的时候
Tasha: Like when you dip beef in egg at the restaurant.
Lucia: 会在蛋里面
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Lucia: 哦有道理
Lucia: Right, got it.
Jake: 这个可以
Jake: This one is okay.
Lucia: 那一会吃火锅
Lucia: Then later we'll have hotpot.
Lucia: 不是吃火锅啊
Lucia: Not hotpot, right?
Jake: 吃水果吃甜点
Jake: We'll have fruits and dessert.
Jake: 这个不说出来的话
Jake: If you don't mention it...
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 这个擦干了吗没擦干
Jake: Did you dry this? It's not dry.
Tasha: 是的老板
Tasha: Yes, boss.
Katrina:  咖啡放桌上了
Jake: The coffee is on the table.
Lucia: 这个干了吧看起来
Lucia: Is this dry? Looks dry.
Lucia: 打奶油吗
Lucia: Making whipped cream, right?
Tasha: 洗5个就行
Tasha: Just wash five.
Tasha: 但是你想吃的话也可以再洗一下
Tasha: But if you want more, you can wash more.
Lucia:  哈哈没事我吃菠萝
Lucia: Haha, no worries, I'll eat pineapple.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 傻只
Lucia: Silly.
Lucia: 要他傻你就知道他在工作OK
Lucia: You can tell he's working if he looks silly, OK?
Tasha: 洗一下
Katrina: Wash it.
Lucia: 好的你这个
Lucia: Okay, cut this in half.
Lucia:  好的你这个房间
Lucia: Okay, this room...
Lucia: 让人看着就有一种workload很重的感觉
Lucia: Just looking at it makes it seem like the workload is heavy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那里好像刚拆了一袋
Lucia: It looks like a bag was just opened there.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 现在开吧
Lucia: Let's start now.
Lucia: 这个还没弄好
Lucia: This isn't ready yet.
Lucia: 还没有刚洗好
Lucia: It hasn't been washed yet.
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Alice: 上面这个刀是干净的
Alice: This knife on top is clean.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 这个板菜板是干净的吗
Lucia: Is this cutting board clean?
Alice: 菜板是干净的
Alice: The cutting board is clean.
Lucia: OK那我在上面切了
Lucia: OK, I'll cut on it then.
Lucia: 这个是草莓的
Lucia: This is for strawberries.
Lucia: 这个绿色的
Lucia: This green one...
Lucia: 这个头要拔下来吗
Lucia: Should I remove the stem?
Lucia: 嗯那我先拔再切好了
Lucia: Hmm, I'll remove it first before cutting.
Alice: 这蛋怎么办
Lucia: What about these eggs?
Alice: 好像没东西吧
Lucia: Seems like there's nothing.
Tasha: 明天用明天奖励煎鸡蛋
Lucia: We'll use them tomorrow, tomorrow we'll reward ourselves with fried eggs.
Alice: 好
Lucia: Alright.
Tasha: 你拿个搓泥吧
Lucia: Get a scrubber.
Lucia: 有网面下有点小的
Lucia: There's a small one under the mesh.
Lucia: 我刚才已经把他片了一刀的那个上哪去了
Lucia: I just sliced it, where did it go?
Lucia: 哎呀这个没切好
Lucia: Oh no, this isn't cut well.
Lucia: 大小差太差太多了
Lucia: The sizes are too different.
Lucia: 这个是用什么打发的
Lucia: What did you use to whip this?
Tasha: 淡奶油
Tasha: Whipping cream.
Lucia: 要加糖吗
Lucia: Do we add sugar?
Lucia: 还是直接打
Lucia: Or whip it directly?
Lucia: 加过了
Lucia: It's already added.
Tasha: 哇哦裱花嘴能拿一个吗
Tasha: Wow, can I get a piping tip?
Lucia: 裱花嘴在哪里放着
Lucia: Where are the piping tips stored?
Tasha: 裱花嘴啊
Lucia: The piping tips...
Tasha: 就在那个架
Lucia: Just on that rack.
Tasha: 微波炉旁边
Tasha: Next to the microwave.
Lucia: 微波炉旁边
Lucia: 好像
Lucia: Seems like it.
Lucia: 没找着哎
Lucia: Can't find it though.
Katrina:  这是做装饰吗
Katrina: Is this for decoration?
Lucia: 哪一个
Katrina: Which one?
Lucia: 对那个是做装饰
Lucia: Yeah, that's for decoration.
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 嗯哪一个什么
Lucia: Hmm, which one are you talking about?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 哦你说的是哎
Lucia: Oh, you mean this one, right?
Lucia: 不是这个吧哎
Lucia: It's not this one, right?
Lucia: 啊我看见裱花袋了
Lucia: Ah, I see the piping bag.
Lucia: 但是裱花嘴是哪个
Lucia: But where's the piping tip?
Katrina:  什么叫裱花袋
Katrina: What's a piping bag?
Lucia: 这个但是裱花嘴我没看到
Lucia: This one, but I didn't see the piping tip.
Katrina:  嗯我是这个可以拿出来了
Katrina: Hmm, should I take this out?
Tasha: 你来拿着吗
Tasha: Are you going to hold it?
Tasha: 你带着眼镜
Tasha: You're wearing glasses.
Lucia: 我老行好好的
Tasha: I'm usually pretty good.
Lucia: 我把这个叉子放回去
Katrina: I'll put this fork back.
Lucia: 但我还没找到那个裱花嘴
Lucia: But I still haven't found the piping tip.
Lucia: 有一个切的不太好
Lucia: One of them isn't cut well.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry about that.
Lucia: 哈哈有一个切的大小就差别太大了
Katrina: Haha, one of them is just too different in size.
Lucia: 那我就打开喽
Lucia: Then I'll just open it.
Lucia: 哇好好看哦
Lucia: Wow, it looks so nice.
Lucia: 是这样拿出来吗
Lucia: Do I take it out like this?
Lucia: 大家快来观摩一下好漂亮
Lucia: Everyone, come and take a look, it's so pretty.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm, amazing.
Lucia: 大家都好厉害
Lucia: Everyone's amazing.
Lucia: 啊哎呦
Lucia: Oh, ouch.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这个我就放在哎
Lucia: I'll just put this... um.
Lucia: 这是刚才从哪拿过来的来着
Lucia: Where did this come from again?
Tasha: 这吗洗在哪
Lucia: Oh, where to wash this?
Lucia: 呃什么洗
Lucia: Uh, what to wash?
Tasha: 裱花嘴哦
Lucia: The piping tip, oh.
Lucia: 那个我刚才也没找到
Lucia: I didn't find that earlier.
Lucia: 你说裱花袋也在这
Lucia: The piping bag is here too.
Lucia: 我看到了
Lucia: I see it.
Lucia: 但是裱花嘴我也没看到
Lucia: But I didn't see the piping tip either.
Lucia: 今天应该把它拿出来
Lucia: We should have taken it out today.
Tasha: 他洗的对
Lucia: He cleaned it, right.
Jake: 我洗的嗯
Jake: I cleaned it, yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈你回忆一下
Lucia: Haha, try to remember.
Lucia: 回忆回忆
Lucia: Think back, think back.
Jake: 难道在这个地方
Jake: Could it be in this place?
Jake: 这些地方
Jake: These places?
Jake: 不能啊
Jake: Can't be.
Jake: 不能够
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这里面也没有
Lucia: It's not in here either.
Lucia: 这应该是
Lucia: This should be...
Lucia: 就是就是普通的磨具
Lucia: Just a regular mold.
Jake: 没有一点线索呢
Jake: It's strange, there's no clue at all.
Jake: 我应该不会扔了吧
Jake: I shouldn't have thrown it away, right?
Lucia: 哎找到了
Lucia: Hey, found it.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 嗯？
Lucia: Huh?
Tasha: 那是转换器
Tasha: That's a converter.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Jake:裱花嘴
Jake: The piping tip.
Jake:是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你的还有一会
Jake: Yours will take a while.
Jake:你的得有个十分钟吧
Jake: Yours will take about ten minutes.
Lucia: 我站这边
Lucia: I'll stand over here.
Jake:我去
Jake: I'll go.
Lucia: 这给他穿过去啊
Lucia: Pass it through to him.
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia: 我把这个擦一下
Lucia: Let me wipe this down.
Tasha: 最后这上面还剩油渣吧
Tasha: There's still some grease left on top, right?
Lucia: 弄下来
Lucia: Get it off.
Tasha: 拽下来
Tasha: Pull it off.
Lucia: OK我是不是一会得把裤子洗下去
Lucia: Okay, I should wash my pants later, right?
Katrina: 哦不是说有洗衣机吗
Katrina: Oh, didn't you say there's a washing machine?
Jake:对在这
Jake: Yeah, it's here.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 哎呀但我要是洗的话
Lucia: Oh, but if I wash it
Lucia: 我明天我要不穿牛仔裤或者之类的啊
Lucia: Tomorrow, I might not wear jeans or something like that
Lucia: 别地方应该没有
Lucia: Nowhere else should be
Jake:牛仔裤跳舞
Jake: Dancing in jeans?
Lucia: 好问题如果要跳舞的话
Lucia: Good question, if we are dancing
Katrina: 跳什么舞还得思考半天
Katrina: What kind of dance, thinking for so long
Lucia: 对如果要跳舞的话
Lucia: Yeah, if we are dancing
Lucia: 我有没有带合适的衣服
Lucia: Do I have the right clothes for it?
Katrina: 不跳那种幅度大的话就穿裙子也可以
Katrina: If it's not a big movement dance, you can wear a skirt
Katrina: 就你今天那个裙子
Katrina: Like the skirt you wore today
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: That works too
Lucia: 嗯我还有个裙子
Lucia: Hmm, I also have a skirt
Lucia: 我带了两条裙子
Lucia: I brought two skirts
Lucia: 一会一会我们再商量商量
Lucia: Let's discuss it later
Katrina: 跳个短短的
Katrina: Just a short dance
Tasha: 好了杨老板给我们买统一服装
Tasha: Alright, Jake will buy us matching outfits
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 我觉得可以有
Lucia: I think that could work
Jake:什么什么样了
Jake: What kind of outfits?
Jake:什么样的服装
Jake: What kind of clothes?
Katrina: 先要确定我们跳什么类型的舞吧
Katrina: First, we need to decide what kind of dance we're doing
Lucia: 取决于我们要跳什么舞
Lucia: It depends on what kind of dance we're doing
Tasha: 就就就IVE穿什么我就穿什么
Tasha: Whatever IVE wears, I'll wear
Katrina: 好多东西都要
Katrina: We need so many things
Katrina: 好多东西都要现买哦
Katrina: We need to buy so many things
Katrina: 好直接逛街去
Katrina: Alright, let's go shopping
Jake:逛街去可以
Jake: Shopping sounds good
Katrina: 戴着眼镜逛街
Katrina: Shopping with glasses on
Tasha: 让我采集一下中国人类
Tasha: Let me gather data on Chinese people
Lucia: 要不戴着眼镜逛淘宝吧也算是一种数据
Lucia: Or how about shopping on Taobao with glasses on, that counts as data too
Katrina: 正在逛淘
Katrina: Already shopping on Taobao
Jake:呃可以啊
Jake: Uh, that works too
Lucia: 哎你的眼镜好了
Lucia: Hey, your glasses are ready
Katrina: 嗯我在看我房间装饰
Katrina: Yeah, I'm looking at room decorations
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 买一个五颜六色的
Katrina: Buying something colorful
Lucia: 这好难哦
Jake:突然有了某些微醺
Jake: Suddenly feeling a bit tipsy
Tasha: 什么好难
Tasha: What's so hard?
Lucia: 装饰房间
Lucia: Decorating the room
Lucia: 装饰房间我说的是
Lucia: I'm talking about decorating the room.
Jake:让大家陪你一起凑单
Jake: Get everyone to chip in with you.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 那我如果买热胶枪的话能报销吗
Lucia: So, if I buy a hot glue gun, can it be reimbursed?
Lucia: 因为假如这口不是
Lucia: Because, if this...
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 他不是很贵
Lucia: It's not very expensive.
Lucia: 他是一个手工很常见的东西
Lucia: It's a common crafting tool.
Jake:行啊可以啊
Jake: Sure, that's fine.
Lucia: 就假如说我们要做水母灯的话
Lucia: Like if we want to make jellyfish lamps.
Katrina: 热熔胶那个
Katrina: The hot glue gun?
Lucia: 可能会用哦
Lucia: We might use it.
Katrina: 就是那个枪那个胶是吧
Katrina: You mean the gun and the glue?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 不是20块钱的
Katrina: It's not more than 20 yuan.
Lucia: 对对那个很便宜
Lucia: Right, it's very cheap.
Lucia: 其实我家里有一个但是好久没用了
Lucia: Actually, I have one at home, but I haven't used it for a long time.
Lucia: 然后我没带过来
Lucia: And I didn't bring it.
Lucia: 因为我不是很确定
Lucia: Because I wasn't sure.
Lucia: 我们具具体会不会用到它
Lucia: If we would actually need it.
Lucia: 20块钱一个跟杨老师
Lucia: 20 yuan per piece, with Jake's approval.
Alice:你下面剪一小口子
Alice: Cut a small slit below.
Alice:要不然你这空气排不下去你就挤不下去
Alice: Otherwise, the air won't escape, and you can't squeeze it out.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Jake:对20块钱确实用不着批准
Jake: Yeah, 20 yuan doesn't need approval.
Alice:你不用那个嘴直接就挤是吧
Alice: You don't use the nozzle, you just squeeze it directly, right?
Tasha: 她没有找着
Tasha: She couldn't find it.
Tasha: 但他是捡快递的走
Tasha: But he's gone to pick up the package.
Lucia: 嗯那你用刀在这里划一下就是
Lucia: Hmm, then use a knife to cut here.
Alice:擦就没了
Alice: Just wipe it, and it's gone.
Lucia: 嗯嗯手小心
Lucia: Hmm, be careful with your hand.
Lucia: 手要要大概要多粗笔画一下在这是吗
Lucia: Should I draw a line here to indicate the size?
Jake:一半
Jake: Halfway.
Tasha: 呃 再往上  好 就这样 就这样
Tasha: Uh, move it up. Okay, just like that.
Lucia: 看一下
Lucia: Take a look.
Tasha: 开
Tasha: Open.
Jake:开开什么
Jake: Open what?
Lucia: 你试一下就可能要用手
Lucia: Try it, you might need to use your hand.
Lucia: 再蹬一蹬
Lucia: Push a little more.
Tasha: 我拧不开必须要剪刀
Tasha: I can't open it, I need scissors.
Lucia: 嗯那怎么办呢
Lucia: Hmm, so what should we do?
Lucia: 那个剪刀够干净吗
Lucia: Are those scissors clean enough?
Jake:不不太够吧
Jake: No, probably not.
Lucia: 此处有掌声
Lucia: Applause here.
Jake:你你怎么操作的
Jake: How did you do it?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:你怎么做的
Jake: How did you do it?
Tasha: 有没有人要来
Tasha: Does anyone want to come?
Lucia: 我要录一下啊
Lucia: I need to record this.
Tasha: 不有没有
Tasha: No, does anyone want to...
Tasha: 人要来挤
Tasha: Come and squeeze?
Lucia: 我们先学习一下
Lucia: Let's learn first.
Tasha: 没有什么学习的
Tasha: There's nothing to learn.
Jake:这我得学习吗
Jake: Do I need to learn this?
Lucia: 这得学得学习
Lucia: Yes, you need to learn this.
Jake:这水平很高啊
Jake: This is a high-level skill.
Katrina: 好有意思
Katrina: So interesting.
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: I'll go.
Alice:我挤的就挤一个点的话又有啥用
Alice: What's the point if I only squeeze one spot?
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Tasha: 杨老板
Tasha: Jake.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来起一个
Jake: Let's start one.
Katrina: 亲自操刀
Katrina: Personally handling it.
Alice:时间
Alice: Time.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈多少有点奇怪
Jake: Hahaha, it's a bit strange.
Lucia: 没事草莓往上一压就看不出来了
Lucia: No worries, just press the strawberry on top and it won't show.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Jake:你来
Jake: You do it.
Jake:最后让眼镜给个评分
Jake: Let's have Glasses give a score at the end.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他有这功能吗
Lucia: Hahaha, does he have that function?
Jake:可以让他有
Jake: We can let him have it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:真好玩
Jake: So much fun.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh dear
Lucia: 为什么我不能在想断的地方把它断掉
Lucia: Why can't I break it at the part I want to?
Katrina: 因为断不了
Katrina: Because it won't break.
Jake:挺好挺好这样挺好
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, this is fine.
Lucia: 下去你给我下去
Lucia: Get down, get down!
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 但是他坠在这里
Lucia: But it's stuck here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 要再来一个吗
Lucia: Do we need another one?
Jake:没墨了
Jake: We're out of ink.
Alice:没让我弄个平
Alice: Didn't let me make it even.
Jake:哦平一点
Jake: Oh, make it more even.
Lucia: 哇可以这个好平
Lucia: Wow, this can be really flat.
Lucia: 对那我再来挤一个好了
Lucia: Yeah, let me squeeze another one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 挤的更够哈哈哈
Tasha: Squeeze more, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 本来想给他画个什么花
Lucia: I was planning to draw a flower.
Lucia: 结果发现画了一个圈之后
Lucia: But after drawing a circle,
Lucia: 也画不出什么了
Lucia: I couldn't draw anything else.
Lucia: 这好奇怪啊
Lucia: This is so strange.
Lucia: 像拔青一样
Lucia: It's like pulling green onions.
Jake:挺好
Jake: It's good.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Lucia: 哈哈等一下
Lucia: Haha, wait a minute.
Jake:这是花
Jake: This is a flower.
Alice:这是食症
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice:祛湿症哈哈哈
Alice: Dispelling dampness, hahaha
Jake:这草
Jake: This is grass.
Lucia: 行再来一个
Lucia: Alright, let's do another one.
Alice:可以画个笑脸
Alice: You can draw a smiley face.
Tasha: 我觉得有点多
Tasha: I think it's a bit much.
Tasha: 大家可以多挤一点
Tasha: Everyone can squeeze more.
Tasha: 最后一个
Tasha: The last one.
Jake:呵压力很大
Jake: Haha, a lot of pressure.
Jake:哈哈哈压力很大
Jake: Hahaha, a lot of pressure.
Lucia: 对对对来个大的哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, let's make a big one, hahaha
Tasha: 嚯 怎么还剩这么大一包
Tasha: Whoa, why is there still such a big pack left?
Tasha: 那这个是不是我
Tasha: Is this me?
Tasha: 草莓
Tasha: Strawberry.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:可以吃了吗
Alice: Can we eat it now?
Lucia: 草莓放冰冰上吃
Lucia: Eat the strawberry on ice.
Jake:压力到我这边
Jake: The pressure is on me.
Tasha: 全部挤掉
Tasha: Squeeze it all out.
Lucia: 挤满吧
Lucia: Fill it up.
Tasha: 这就是你了
Tasha: This is you.
Jake:挤满到我这边挤来
Jake: Squeeze it all out on my side.
Lucia: 哎这还怪好看的
Lucia: Hey, this actually looks pretty good.
Lucia: 哎果然没有压力就是不一样
Lucia: See, without pressure, it's different.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你倒的奶油太多
Tasha: You put too much cream.
Katrina: 这颜色好看
Katrina: The color looks nice.
Lucia: 给哪个少的再加一点
Lucia: Add a bit more to the one with less.
Lucia: 如果哪位同学会吃掉他
Lucia: If any student can eat it.
Jake:哎这样挺好可以吃的话
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good if it can be eaten.
Lucia: 啊好看耶
Lucia: Ah, it looks nice.
Jake:水平还是高
Jake: The skill level is high.
Tasha: 专业
Tasha: Professional.
Jake:巨石阵批发
Jake: Stonehenge wholesale.
Lucia: 巨石阵批发
Lucia: Stonehenge wholesale.
Jake:哎哎这个3个变成了10个
Jake: Hey, these three became ten.
老板：哈哈哈哈哈
Boss: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Katrina: 喷出来了
Katrina: It splashed out.
Katrina: 主大一个不浪费
Katrina: Don't waste a drop.
Alice:直接往里吸溜吧
Alice: Just slurp it up directly.
Lucia: 好好草莓
Lucia: Alright, strawberry.
Katrina: 草莓奶油苹果
Katrina: Strawberry cream apple.
Lucia: 奶油苹果
Lucia: Cream apple.
Alice:好我要这个
Alice: Okay, I want this one.
Jake:拍一张
Jake: Take a photo.
Katrina: 对拍一张
Katrina: Yeah, take a photo.
Tasha: 艺术草莓
Tasha: Artistic strawberry.
Jake:哈哈我的艺术草莓
Jake: Haha, my artistic strawberry.
Jake:我的我的
Jake: Mine, mine.
Jake:挺好的我很开心哈哈哈
Jake: It's good, I'm very happy, hahaha.
Tasha: 好丑啊
Tasha: That's so ugly.
Jake:不丑啊这个各有特色
Jake: It's not ugly, it has its own charm.
Jake:真的是你远远看的
Jake: Really, from a distance...
Lucia: 对不丑不丑各有物色
Lucia: Yeah, not ugly, just unique.
Jake:真不知道是什么哈哈哈
Jake: I really have no idea what it is, hahaha.
Alice:我来接一个吧
Alice: Let me take one.
Lucia: 我先把我点的这个跟巨石阵一样
Lucia: I'll finish the one I ordered first, it looks like Stonehenge.
Lucia: 给吃了吧
Lucia: Let's eat it.
Katrina: 再不要这个
Katrina: No more of this.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:谢谢谢谢您
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Katrina: 再把我这个
Katrina: And mine too.
Jake:这该怎么下口呢
Jake: How should I start eating this?
Alice:先舔一下
Alice: Lick it first.
Alice:扭一扭扭一扭
Alice: Twist it, twist it.
Jake:泡一泡
Jake: Soak it.
Jake:结果没有
Jake: It didn't work.
Jake:那就硬吃是吧
Jake: So just eat it directly, right?
Lucia: 嗯好好吃
Lucia: Hmm, so tasty.
Lucia: 这个奶油调的也好好
Lucia: This cream is really good too.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:第一视角是是是巨石阵
Jake: The first person view is like Stonehenge.
Jake:吃蛋糕嗯
Jake: Eating cake, hmm.
Jake:眼线先吃
Jake: Start with the frosting.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好敬业哈哈哈
Lucia: So dedicated, hahaha.
Lucia: 我应该怎样才能把它撕开
Lucia: How can I tear it open?
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Whoa, that scared me.
Alice:哎楼下这个厕所门是坏的
Alice: Hey, the bathroom door downstairs is broken.
Alice:还是上面的坏的
Alice: Or is it the one upstairs?
Lucia: 好像俩都是坏的
Lucia: Seems like both are broken.
Jake:是好的呀
Jake: No, one is fine.
Jake:就那个是坏的
Jake: Only that one is broken.
Alice:就锁不了
Alice: It just can't lock.
Jake:就那个是好的应该
Jake: That one should be good.
Alice:那洗澡的话
Alice: What about showering?
Katrina: 楼上的楼上的这个是好的
Katrina: The one upstairs, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦不这个是坏的
Lucia: Oh no, this one's broken.
Katrina: 我可以锁上
Katrina: I can lock it.
Lucia: 啊这个吗
Lucia: Ah, this one?
Katrina: 嗯就把他那个一拨一下就好
Katrina: Hmm, just turn it slightly and it's fine.
Lucia: 你说的是这边这个还是那边那个
Lucia: Are you talking about this one here or that one over there?
Katrina: 我你房间那个啊
Katrina: The one in your room.
Alice:这个是好的吗
Alice: Is this one okay?
Lucia: 那个是好的那个好像
Lucia: That one seems fine.
Lucia: 反正我没锁上
Lucia: Anyway, I didn't lock it.
Lucia: 也可能是我操作有误
Lucia: Maybe I did it wrong.
Katrina: 他不是往左还是往右
Katrina: Isn't it left or right?
Jake:哎呀  完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Katrina: 拨一下就可以锁上
Katrina: Just turn it and it will lock.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 3秒钟过了
Katrina: Three seconds have passed.
Jake:完了
Jake: It's over.
Alice:你可以从外面打开一下吗
Alice: Can you open it from the outside?
Alice:我看能锁上没
Alice: Let me see if it can lock.
Jake:这个应该不行
Jake: This probably won't work.
Jake:我理解算了吧
Jake: I think we should give up.
Alice:嗯锁不了
Alice: Hmm, it can't be locked.
Alice:坏一点
Alice: It's a bit broken.
Katrina: 你看我眼睛上的彩虹
Katrina: Look at the rainbow in my eyes.
Lucia: 哈哈不是你烤的吗
Lucia: Haha, didn't you bake it?
Lucia: 大家一起烤的
Lucia: We all baked it together.
Lucia: 关键还是有你的指导和经验烤的
Lucia: The key thing is your guidance and experience.
Lucia: 鼓掌哈哈哈
Lucia: Applause, haha.
Jake:鼓掌
Jake: Applause.
Tasha: 明天可以做进阶版的
Tasha: We can make an advanced version tomorrow.
Tasha: 就是他吃了之后会爆浆里面哦
Tasha: When you eat it, it will burst inside.
Lucia: 这么酷哈哈哈我以为
Lucia: So cool, haha. I always thought...
Lucia: 我一直以为
Lucia: I always thought...
Lucia: 这种东西
Lucia: Things like this...
Lucia: 就是只有蛋糕店才可以做出来
Lucia: Can only be made in cake shops.
Lucia: 就是单靠个人的力量是做不出来的
Lucia: They can't be made by individuals alone.
Lucia: 哈哈只有一种神秘力量才能做出来
Lucia: Haha, only some mysterious power can create it.
Lucia: 我们的神秘力量
Lucia: Our mysterious power.
Jake:我们的
Jake: Ours.
Alice:我吃过两个
Alice: I've eaten two.
Katrina: 等一会等一会吃嘛
Katrina: Wait a bit, let's eat later.
Katrina: 我等一会就会消化
Katrina: I'll digest in a while.
Alice:谁没吃过两个
Alice: Who hasn't eaten two?
Katrina: 我还没吃过两个
Katrina: I haven't eaten two yet.
Lucia: 我还没吃过两个
Lucia: I haven't eaten two yet.
Tasha: 他还没吃啊
Tasha: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:啊我怎么没吃
Jake: Huh, why haven't I eaten?
Jake:我刚吃完就没吃
Jake: I just finished eating and now I haven't eaten.
Jake:哪个是我的
Jake: Which one is mine?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Katrina: 谁看见我线了
Katrina: Has anyone seen my cable?
Katrina: 就剩一个头了
Katrina: There's only a head left.
Jake:什么线嗯
Jake: What cable, huh?
Jake:iPhone的线吗
Jake: The iPhone cable?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:iPhone的线
Jake: The iPhone cable.
Alice:嗯致死量的糖
Alice: Yeah, a lethal amount of sugar.
Alice:快晕过去了
Alice: I'm about to pass out.
Alice:被你甜晕了
Alice: You made me faint with sweetness.
Alice:哈哈哈你的甜蜜攻击
Alice: Haha, your sweet attack.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 好好好
Tasha: Okay, okay, okay.
Alice:俘获我的心
Alice: You've captured my heart.
Alice:哈哈好好好
Alice: Haha, okay, okay, okay.
Alice:我今天晚上想洗个澡
Alice: I want to take a bath tonight.
Tasha: 你要不要去楼上洗
Tasha: Do you want to go upstairs to shower?
Jake:喂他我
Jake: Hey, I
Jake:我给你看一下
Jake: I'll show you.
Jake:那是不是你
Jake: Is that you?
Alice:开了灯有有声音的话应该也没人进
Alice: If the lights are on and there's noise, no one should come in.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Katrina: 你去去楼上洗呗
Katrina: You go shower upstairs.
Lucia: 楼上全是女生没事
Lucia: It's all girls upstairs, it's fine.
Alice:明天不想化妆了
Alice: I don't want to put on makeup tomorrow.
Alice:化妆好累还得卸
Alice: Makeup is so tiring, and I still have to take it off.
Alice:我现在这样躺床上睡觉
Alice: I'm going to sleep on my bed like this now.
Katrina: 你们一般几点睡
Katrina: What time do you usually sleep?
Alice:我昨天3点多睡的
Alice: I slept past 3 AM yesterday.
Tasha: 他每天只需要睡24个小时
Tasha: He only needs to sleep 24 hours a day.
Alice:no那是以前
Alice: No, that was before.
Jake:应该是你的摸错了是吧
Jake: It should be yours, did you get it wrong?
Katrina: 不是我是那个苹果壳
Katrina: No, it's the Apple case.
Katrina: 哎哎哎苹果壳在这我试试
Katrina: Hey, hey, hey, the Apple case is here, let me try.
Jake:明天还要买什么呀
Jake: What else do we need to buy tomorrow?
Katrina: 不用买呀
Katrina: No need to buy it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 停止外送旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Stop delivering the Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 这两个34G的下单
Katrina: Order these two 34G ones.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 时钟你买是吧
Katrina: You’re buying the clock, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 这个我买了
Katrina: I bought this one.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 234 他买就行
Katrina: 234, he can buy it.
Alice:今晚上是不是又要看那个装修
Alice: Are we watching that renovation show again tonight?
Alice:装 不 装饰
Alice: Deco... decoration?
Katrina: 还要看一下跳什么舞
Katrina: We still need to see which dance to perform.
Jake:嗯对跳跳舞
Jake: Yeah, let's dance.
Alice:装饰的
Alice: The decoration one.
Jake:装饰的装饰一下
Jake: The decoration, let’s decorate.
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decorate.
Alice:我想跟你睡一起了
Alice: I want to sleep with you.
Alice:我可以抄你的装饰
Alice: Can I copy your decoration?
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decoration.
Jake:装修的话
Jake: About the renovation...
Lucia: 我刚才也在想
Lucia: I was just thinking...
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学把自己的房间装修
Lucia: Did any of our classmates renovate their rooms?
Lucia: 给我抄一抄
Lucia: Can I copy it?
Jake:哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:装修可能讨论讨论
Jake: We can discuss the renovation.
Katrina: 小红书照着买吧
Katrina: Just follow what’s on Xiaohongshu.
Jake:就是多开个PPT开个投影
Jake: Let's open a PPT and a projector.
Jake:聊聊天看看图之类的啊
Jake: Chat, look at some pictures, stuff like that.
Alice:啊看看组
Alice: Ah, look at the group.
Jake:是看看图看看图
Jake: Yeah, look at pictures.
Jake:刷刷网页
Jake: Browse the web.
Alice:是自己的房间吗
Alice: Is it for our own rooms?
Jake:对啊互相扯扯
Jake: Yeah, just talk about it.
Jake:就是就互相扯扯
Jake: Just chat about it.
Lucia: 我们做完设计以后还要做一个PPT
Lucia: Do we need to make a PPT after designing?
Lucia: 向大家汇报一下吗
Lucia: To report to everyone?
Jake:呃PPT不用做
Jake: No need for a PPT.
Jake:就看网页就好了
Jake: Just browse the web.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 看网页
Katrina: Browsing websites.
Katrina: 直接用这个
Katrina: Just use this.
Katrina: 看手机不就行了
Katrina: Why not just look at your phone?
Jake:哦也对
Jake: Oh, yeah, that's true.
Jake:就是手机互相传阅是吧
Jake: So, you mean sharing stuff on phones, right?
Katrina: 为什么要看别人的
Katrina: Why look at other people's?
Jake:你自己看是吧
Jake: You'll just look at your own, right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:哦你们要偷偷的自己搞
Jake: Oh, you guys are just gonna do your own thing secretly.
Jake:不跟别人分享
Jake: Not sharing with anyone else.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:你原来是
Jake: So you originally...
Alice:那我的原来花里胡哨乱搞风
Alice: My style was always flashy and chaotic.
Jake:应该是
Jake: It should be...
Katrina: 倒也不是
Katrina: Not really.
Katrina: 我也是我要搞五颜六色
Katrina: I also want to go colorful.
Lucia: 可是墙上不能贴的话
Lucia: But if we can't stick things on the wall...
Lucia: 我在想我应该怎么弄
Lucia: I'm wondering what I should do.
Katrina: 美文纸明天叫个外送看看
Katrina: How about ordering some nice paper tomorrow?
Katrina: 如果他要是真的效果挺好的话就可以
Katrina: If it actually works well, then it's fine.
Jake:你们都吃完了
Jake: Are you all done eating?
Jake:就剩我一个了
Jake: I'm the only one left.
Katrina: 我我还有一个
Katrina: I still have one more.
Katrina: 我等会我等会
Katrina: Wait a moment, wait a moment.
Katrina: 工作一会我又饿了
Katrina: After working for a bit, I get hungry again.
Jake:对工作工作
Jake: Yeah, work, work.
Katrina: 就是现在还没有消化
Katrina: I haven't digested yet.
Katrina: 我是那种吃的很少
Katrina: I eat very little.
Katrina: 但是我就是呃
Katrina: But I, um...
Katrina: 吃的少但是也饱的快
Katrina: I eat little, but I get full quickly.
Katrina: 饱的快小鸟胃马上又又饿了
Katrina: I get full quickly, but then I get hungry again like a bird.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Like a bird.
Katrina: 饿的也快
Katrina: I get hungry quickly too.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Like a bird.
Lucia: 好难想啊
Lucia: It's so hard to think.
Alice:好折磨我呀
Alice: It's torturing me.
Lucia: 为什么我们突然播出了这个环节呢
Lucia: Why did we suddenly broadcast this segment?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:我们用完之后
Alice:用完之后没
Alice: After using it, did you...
Jake:我们的计划
Jake: Our plan is...
Alice:接东西
Alice: Take the stuff...
Jake:我们给你们的保底计划
Jake: Our backup plan for you...
Jake:我们原来是说我们会出一个方案
Jake: We initially said we'd come up with a plan...
Jake:然后如果你们这个方案能你
Jake: And if your plan can...
Jake:你们能整个挪活的话
Jake: If you can execute it...
Jake:那就用你们的方案
Jake: Then we'll use your plan.
Jake:就是我们尽量的整活
Jake: We'll do our best to make it work.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊 出去玩去吧
Katrina: Ah, let's go out and play.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:那这些东西
Alice: Then these things...
Alice:扔哪去什么这些
Alice: Where should we throw them?
Alice:就是用完之后的
Alice: The things we've used...
Alice:没用完的
Alice: The things we haven't used...
Lucia: 好饱啊哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm so full, haha.
Katrina: 你好呀
Katrina: Hi there.
Lucia: 哈哈突然出现啊
Lucia: Haha, you suddenly appeared.
Alice:被你吓了一跳
Alice: You scared me.
Katrina: 挑一挑
Katrina: Just picking something.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 因为懒得把这挪走
Lucia: I was too lazy to move this.
Lucia: 就直接坐在这个小马上了
Lucia: So I just sat on this little horse.
Alice:是不是该刷碗了
Alice: Should we wash the dishes?
Alice:好痛苦啊
Alice: It's so painful.
Alice:老师会说真读假读真的
Alice: The teacher will say whether it's true or not.
Alice:我们外卖还没扔呢
Alice: We haven't thrown out our takeout yet.
Lucia: 哦对我们剩的外卖还没有收拾
Lucia: Oh right, we haven't cleaned up our leftover takeout.
Alice:上边的
Alice: The ones on top...
Alice:还没收拾
Alice: Haven't cleaned up yet.
Jake:啊什么东西
Jake: Ah, what is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:啥啥
Jake: What, what?
Jake:是啊什么东西
Jake: Yeah, what is it?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Jake:是啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈打哑谜洗了
Lucia: Haha, playing dumb.
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈好行
Jake: Oh oh oh, haha, okay.
Jake:我们给你们
Jake: We'll give you guys
Jake:我们有一些proposal
Jake: We have some proposals.
Jake:一个是
Jake: One is
Lucia: 说来听听
Lucia: Let's hear it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:嗯也不是
Jake: Hmm, not really.
Jake:就是这中间几天怎么整活了
Jake: It's more like how to handle things these days.
Jake:一些proposal
Jake: Some proposals.
Alice:哎眼镜呢
Alice: Hey, where are my glasses?
Lucia: 给我们一些灵感嘛
Lucia: Give us some inspiration.
Lucia: 说不定我们听了之后会有更多的ID的
Lucia: Maybe after hearing it, we'll have more ideas.
Jake:你的眼镜好了
Jake: Your glasses are ready.
Katrina: 我的风铃挂在哪里呢
Katrina: Where should I hang my wind chime?
Lucia: 网好差呀
Lucia: The internet is so bad.
Katrina: 刷不出东西
Katrina: I can't load anything.
Jake:哎老三呢
Jake: Hey, where's the third one?
Alice:上楼了拿东西去
Alice: Went upstairs to get something.
Jake:这是他手机
Jake: This is his phone.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:你给他带上
Jake: Take it to him.
Lucia: 咱这有洗衣机吗
Lucia: Do we have a washing machine?
Jake:有就在那边
Jake: Yes, it's over there.
Lucia: 看看这个
Lucia: Look at this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊他前面被堵住了
Lucia: Ah, it's blocked in front.
Lucia: 门口应该有个灯
Lucia: There should be a light at the door.
Lucia: 让我研究一下
Lucia: Let me figure it out.
Lucia: 咱们需要洗衣服的数据吗
Lucia: Do we need data for laundry?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:呃可以有
Jake: Uh, could be useful.
Jake:可以洗
Jake: It can wash.
Lucia: 因为我想把我这个裤子洗一下
Lucia: Because I want to wash my pants.
Lucia: 不过我光手洗一下
Lucia: But I'll just hand wash them.
Lucia: 那个沾到沾到奶油的地方
Lucia: The part that got cream on it.
Jake:那也可以用它 对
Jake: You can use it too, yeah.
Lucia: 或者就是直接撂进去
Lucia: Or just throw it in directly.
Lucia: 他这有洗衣液
Lucia: There's detergent here.
Lucia: 哎还真有
Lucia: Oh, there really is.
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊好全啊
Lucia: Ah, that's so complete.
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Hmm, ah.
Lucia: 我想想
Lucia: Let me think.
Lucia: 那我又要上去一下了
Lucia: Then I need to go up again.
Lucia: 让我换个裤子就下来
Lucia: Let me change my pants and I'll come down.
Jake:有一个火锅抽奖   抽食材
Jake: There's a hotpot lottery, draw for ingredients.
Jake:抽食材抽到什么吃什么
Jake: Whatever ingredient you draw, you eat.
Jake:哈哈就是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's the idea.
Alice:你的眼镜好了
Alice: Your glasses are ready.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice:me
Alice: Me
Katrina: 这也是要自己做的这个
Katrina: This also needs to be done by ourselves.
Lucia: 来观摩一下什么
Lucia: Let's observe what?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 来观摩一下你打算怎么改造你的房间
Lucia: Let's see how you plan to remodel your room.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 设计专业的
Katrina: It's design major stuff.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈procreate专业
Lucia: Haha, procreate major.
Jake:完了你设计完估计还要做president大家
Jake: Once you're done with the design, you'll probably have to present it to everyone.
Alice:什么president
Alice: What do you mean by present it?
Katrina: 别吓唬他
Katrina: Don't scare him.
Jake:就是要
Jake: I mean...
Jake:呃秀硕给你讲一遍
Jake: Uh, Shure will explain it to you.
Jake:就是秀硕把你的房间帮你讲一遍
Jake: Shure can explain your room to you.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, ah.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:没有没有没有乱说
Jake: No, no, I'm just kidding.
Lucia: 我们还有这个环节
Lucia: We even have this segment?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就是我是说
Jake: I mean...
Jake:他可能最后能做出个视频出来
Jake: He might be able to make a video in the end.